[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's contractually obligated
to never sleep again thankfully i know
just the thing to help with that the
mandela catalog a terrifying series of
six videos here on youtube that are
guaranteed to give you nightmare fuel
for weeks produced by alex kister the
mandela catalog is the latest and
greatest example from the increasingly
popular world of analog horror think
local 58 gemini home entertainment the
walton files apparently there was just
something about the 1980s that was
utterly terrifying
oh no those shoulder pads there they're
so big
is that thing a cell phone or a brick
kill it kill it with fire
ex-president ronald reagan no no get
back get back i can't handle your
trickle-down economics anyway all joking
aside the mandela catalog tells its
terrifying tale through a series of
1980s and 90s era vhs tapes all
originating in the mysterious mandela
county where children have started to go
missing and a mysterious intruder is
breaking into local homes but what
begins as a few simple home videos
quickly descends into a tale of
kidnapping body swapping religious
conspiracy and metaphysics this one is
gonna get dark friends so buckle up
while we try to crack open the unholy
horrors that exist inside the mandela
catalog
it's hard to say exactly where we should
start this series considering the first
posted video isn't the one that the
creator suggests watching first but this
upload overthrown does set up our key
theme so i think starting here still
makes the most sense in it we're
presented with an animated version of
the birth of jesus coming specifically
from a video series called the
beginner's bible and yeah it gives you
the classic tale of an angel gabriel
descending from heaven to tell mary that
she'll be giving birth to the savior
jesus christ who'll bless us with love
and joy and amazing black friday deals
for everyone on our christmas list ah it
is so nice to remember the reason for
the season except this time the nativity
story is just a little bit different our
angel's name is redacted and his face
has been censored for a brief moment
though we glimpse behind the sensor bar
to see this what looks to be a blue
alien rips straight out of james
cameron's avatar as he speaks he
glitches on the word angel
i am the
angel gabriel already you can tell that
something is going wrong here a
suspicion that only grows once gabriel
starts speaking in binary
[Music]
apparently the angels we have heard on
high are very proficient with their ones
and zeros turning on closed captions we
see that whispers translate to a code
that reads i am the one true savior i
must reverse the delusion joseph is next
and indeed joseph stepfather of jesus is
next as he sleeps the angel speaks to
fear him this is like the worst asmr
video lastly we see the shepherds in the
field meeting our angel who once again
declares himself to be the one true
savior
smash cut to black before we get red
text saying i deceived them such weak
minds yep we're in that part of youtube
again friends sweet dreams everyone
alright but let's get a grip on
everything that we're seeing here first
whatever this thing is it ain't an angel
notice that only after it says i know
everything about what makes you human
does it reveal a human face this thing
is a shape shifter and its true form is
what we saw at the beginning before the
sensor bar went up that weird blue alien
face notice too that it stumbles over
the word angel getting stuck on the
letter a almost as though it was trying
to say i am the alien and then
correcting itself to me this whole thing
is very reminiscent of the ancient
aliens theory the idea that some
intelligent extraterrestrials visited
earth in the prehistoric days and in the
process spawned all human conceptions of
gods and religions as humans were unable
to comprehend what they had just
witnessed but let me be perfectly clear
here i'm not married to that theory
there's also plenty of evidence to
suggest that this angel is in fact the
devil himself satan again with closed
captions turned on we get a special
secret while the screen's black hidden
in the closed captions is this message
quote how frozen i became and powerless
then ask it not reader for i write it
not because all language would be
insufficient i did not die and i alive
remained not think for thyself now hast
thou ought of wit this quote well poetic
is actually a direct excerpt from a
classic work of literature called
dante's inferno specifically a part near
the end of kanto 34. for those who don't
know dante's inferno is basically just a
dude's trip through the various circles
of h-e-double toothpicks and this quote
is coming from the end of his tour when
dante's in the frozen center of it all
and there he encounters satan himself
chewing on some sinners in fact this
line is his reaction to seeing the giant
behemoth that is satan and he's not just
chewing on any sinners he's chewing on
some liars and frauds judas who lied to
and betrayed jesus as well as brutus and
cassius the two men who betrayed and
murdered julius caesar so we see that
fraud is the biggest sin as defined by
the inferno the same type of fraud that
we see our angel committing to marry
joseph and the shepherds in the mandela
catalog could our angel then potentially
be satan himself it seems likely in the
final upload of season one titled
exhibition we get another hidden quote
in the closed captions this time a bible
verse corinthians 11 14. isn't it
obvious that it's disgraceful for a man
to have long hair oh wait sorry sorry
wrong corinthians that's one corinthians
not two corinthians sorry but cheese
bible really pushing everyone to get
their sick fate on huh anyway after a
long section talking about whether girls
can pray with their heads uncovered or
whether they just need to shave off
their hair here's the right quote for
you and no wonder for satan disguises
himself as an angel of light i mean that
right there seems pretty explicit and
just to hammer the point home in another
video warning about how people in this
universe are losing their minds to a
disorder called mad we're told to quote
avoid religious practices which again
seems like this is a world where satan
or that blue avatar alien take your pick
has misled the masses and has seized
control of the world's religions
manipulating their minds and causing
them to go crazy so it would seem that
satan has come to deceive the world but
why is he waiting all the way until the
80s to do anything with that and what
exactly is his plan well either satan's
a big fan of bon jovi or it has
something to do with the analog part of
analog horror the television you see the
80s was perhaps the golden age
television it was when cable became
popular suddenly instead of three
channels you had dozens it was when the
video cassette recorder allowed viewers
to tape their favorite shows it was when
the tv remote allowed people to veg out
on the couch and just surf in short the
tv rose to prominence during this decade
and with it the ability to reach the
masses almost anytime anywhere something
that a fake brainwashing angel would
probably love to exploit in the final
upload of season 1 we see that the
government has issued something called
the television and mirror destruction
order saying that if a loved one is
coming to contact with one of these
items you have to contact the local
authorities right away in other words
tvs are dangerous in this universe and
also
mirrors so let's reflect on that one
thing that keeps getting brought up in
the mandela catalog is fear gabriel
talks about how he desires to know the
fear of joseph and the shepherds in
another video a training tape for
emergency responders they're expressly
told to not talk to victims on the phone
because you might accidentally reveal
your fear there's something absolutely
chilling when you see an emergency
services training video telling the only
people who can help in a dire situation
to cower in fear and let the innocents
die and in yet another video we see an
emergency alert about an onslaught of
missing children that warns parents to
keep their kids away from televisions
because they might project frightening
imagery it would seem then that some
entity satan or whoever is using the tvs
to broadcast fears into people's minds
and into their homes this again seems to
coincide with the 1980s setting for this
thing and specifically the birth of the
24-hour news cycle in 1980 the cable
channel cnn launched and in the process
pioneered news as round-the-clock
programming suddenly it wasn't just a
short one hour update at the end of each
night it was instead like sports live
and updating with all the latest and all
the worst headlines that humanity had to
offer at any hour of any day a trend
that is only accelerated with the
internet and things like twitter now
obviously i'm just making an analogy
here a comparison to what's going on in
the series but it does seem like
something that's happening here in the
mandela catalog in the season one finale
we get a series of home videos by a
young man named mark heathcliff he's
important for a lot of other reasons
that we'll talk about later throughout
his tapes though nothing much happens
some church imagery a door mysteriously
opening and closing in the dark but then
we see this
a figure approaching him through a tv at
night we get this assessment from the
cops that are looking at the footage
quote heathcliff has been paranoid for a
prolonged period to me it seems to
suggest that the tv was the thing that
was causing his paranoia whether
literally summing a shadow monster to
taunt him or else symbolically causing
him to succumb to his darkest fears in
fact the tv does appear to offer a
physical portal in people's homes upload
number four intruder alert shows us this
man who is more than happy to whisper to
us
well uh that's a comforting thought can
you feed the cat while you're in there
also notice the whispered voice sounds a
lot like our angel friend anyway
throughout this video we see him
repeatedly appearing in televisions
which would be scary on its own and it
is but he also appears to be stealing
children out of their beds midway
through the video we get a psa about the
importance of taking care of your
children the psa presents us with a
crying baby who when checked on by his
mommy has vanished out of its crib the
only person that was in the room the tv
intruder and we know that he can get
into and out of the house presumably
through the tv as we see later in the
same video our intruder roaming the
house of the vanished child hidden in
the shadows we're told that
3426 children have gone missing over the
past several weeks so it looks like our
dude here has been pretty darn busy why
what's he doing with all these children
and how is he doing it is it just sci-fi
can he just teleport between tv screens
well yeah it kind of seems like that the
video tells us that quote they exist on
different spectrums suggesting that this
person this intruder may have the
ability to appear and disappear from
different spectra perhaps one that
allows him to physically be broadcast
into a home or at the very least exist
on a different plane of reality and
appear and disappear at will as we see
in the short mad disorder video an
entity is invisible it fades in to tell
its victim something and then it fades
away as if it were phasing in and out of
reality and if this intruder is in some
way related to the satan angel or is
himself satan then the ability to do
that to appear and disappear at will
isn't all that far-fetched which brings
us to what's actually getting whispered
here in the mad disorder video we're
told that whatever's being said it
drives the victim insane causing them to
in 97 of cases end their own life but
what information is actually being
spread here what is prompting all this
fear well the title of the video in this
case might be our biggest clue mad in
the context of the mandela catalog is
short for something called metaphysical
awareness disorder though we're never
told what this thing is only the deadly
end results of what coming down with it
entails based on the words alone i think
we can get a pretty solid guess as to
what it means metaphysics is all about
the nature of reality what exists how
does it exist basically a subject that
is beyond our physical world and basic
five senses and the word awareness is
just that you're suddenly made aware of
something so what we have here is that
this intruder or these otherworldly
beings are telling their targets the
nature of reality or maybe a lie about
it which in turn causes the victim to
lose their mind and ultimately end their
own life actually very reminiscent of
the opening lines of h.p lovecraft's
call of cthulhu which is also about
reality our existence and how we can
never truly comprehend the nature of
that existence quote the most merciful
thing in the world i think is the
inability of the human mind to correlate
all its contents we live on a placid
island of ignorance in the midst of
black seas of infinity and it was not
meant that we should voyage far the
sciences each draining in its own
direction have hitherto harmed us little
but someday the piecing together of
dissociated knowledge will open up such
terrifying vistas of reality and of our
frightful position therein that we shall
either go mad from the revelation or
flee from the light into the peace and
safety of a new dark age in short this
is what i think's going on with the mad
disorder in mandela catalog other
worldly beings telling people about
their place in reality and us humans are
just unable to comprehend it which leads
to a sudden and tragic end of our lives
as the video says only three percent are
able to be cured of this and if these
quote unquote angels are indeed some
sort of demon or alien well those are
the exact type of creatures that would
be able to speak on something like the
subject of reality so in summary we have
ourselves satan or some alien but
probably satan disguising himself as a
human to shape the world's religions
he's spreading fear via the newest and
hottest technology of the 80s television
and also spreading words about the true
nature of reality in order to crush the
lies of anyone he tells meanwhile we
have another intruder which may or may
not be the same character using the
spectrum of television to enter homes
and steal away thousands of children
talk about your feel-good horror stories
for the holiday season and i'm not even
done there's still a lot more to this
story in the form of alternates
unstoppable mutant doppelgangers as well
as a mysterious society that's trying to
piece things all back together with the
help of a dead man and here's the twist
friends this guy may not be as evil as
he first appears but all that and more
on the next installment because let me
tell ya there's a lot to cover here so
in the meantime you want to learn a
mind-bending metaphysical truth about
the world that won't cause you to go
insane traditional wallets suck they're
big they're bulky they barely fit in
your pockets and they cause you back
problems when you sit on them the ridge
wallet on the other hand our sponsor for
today's episode has descended like an
angel on high to be the savior for all
our wallet needs the ridge completely
upends everything you thought you knew
about wallets gone is your dad's chunky
waddle leather and in is the ridge a
thin sleek durable wallet that slides
right into your front pocket and comes
in 30 different styles from burnt
titanium to metal damascus that one's my
personal favorite to literal gold you
guys know at this point that i use all
the products that we promote during
these end cards right but let me tell
you i use use the ridge wallet like
every day in fact i love the product so
much that completely unsponsored from
all of this actually bought one for my
father and also my father-in-law and
then one for my mother-in-law because
she wanted a wallet too after she saw my
father-in-law's and also i gave one to
my buddy tyler williams from sophia
nygaard's channel in total i gotta say
i've given away like i don't know at
least eight of these things to family
and friends as gifts no one has ever
gone back to using their original wallet
after trying it but even if they wanted
to trying the ridge is risk-free since
they let you test drive one for 45 days
and if you find out that you don't love
it as much as i did you just send it on
back for a full refund oh and remember
all those amazing christmas deals
redacted wanted to tell us about well
one is 10 off your entire order of ridge
wallets using our coupon code all you
have to do is go to ridge.com
film theory the link is in the top line
of the description and use the code film
theory
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y at checkout for 10
off your entire holiday order and if you
wind up like me and are buying these
things in bulk that means that you are
getting a lot of savings seriously the
ridge is the perfect stocking stuffer
for the wallet users in your life
whether or not they realize that better
wallet alternatives are out there so
give them the gift of comfort security
and style with the ridge wallet link is
down in the description below or use the
code film theory at checkout now if
you'll excuse me i need to phase into a
different plane of existence until next
week's episode so in the meantime
remember it's all just a theory a film
theory and cut